but in the division where one of the
teams will play tonight and another one
of the teams will play tomorrow night
the giants taking control fourth
straight win
going to seattle and doing what few can
ever do
beating
the seahawks are you kidding me the
seahawks struggled last monday night
with the eagles
and then they lost not to daniel jones
not to phil sims
not to eli manning
they lost to my new hero i think i'm
gonna get myself a colt mccoy jersey
because as i said last week that guy
hanging around
for 11 years in the nfl right not
playing
making bank
right to not play football
a texas quarterback chris sims actually
likes and me
he is i like colt mccoy i like colt
mccoy better major apple white now okay
and
and
but but uh you know you call his number
once in a while and and he gets it done
it helps that the defense
holds russell wilson a company to 12
points but my god it just shows you that
whole any given sunday thing
it really does apply even when you're
given 10 points even when someone thinks
the seahawks will easily cover that 10
points and makes it one of his best bets
it can blow up in your face yeah well i
mean it's the nfl i i know it gets
misleading sometimes we see records and
star players and we think there's no way
this team can compete with that team but
you know we all fall in the trap and we
all know and you know stupidly or not we
all know that the league is so close
even between the best teams and the
worst teams and the giants are one of
those teams right now that are like yeah
it's not real pretty but they're
climbing the hill and on an upward
trajectory we've seen it the last few
weeks even though we're not like oh my
gosh this is the most amazing rise we've
ever seen it's still going in the right
direction the seattle seahawks it's the
opposite over the last three or four
weeks it's not like it's falling off a
cliff but it's kind of slowly going
downhill here to where yeah there's
questions and you could see yesterday
that there wasn't a whole lot of a
different look between the two teams on
the football field uh seattle blew a few
opportunities we know that but you know
all in all that's life in the nfl it's a
crazy league it really is it was a fun
game to watch even though it was low
scoring and ugly
when you look back at what the giants
have done this year and yes it was a
difficult early stretch to the season
but
they they never embarrassed themselves
the only game that went sideways for
them was the 49ers game they had the
steelers on the ropes late in the third
quarter feels like yesterday we were
talking about the bud dupree hit on
daniel jones that pops the ball into the
air and cam hayward catches it in the
end zone at a point where the giants
could have taken the lead and really
putting the the fear into a team that is
now 11-0 and tries to go 12-0 tonight at
home against washington the bears game
was close they had a lead in that game
yeah the rams game was a one score game
cowboys 37 34. then then uh they lost
the eagles by one they had the
buccaneers were on the road
on a monday night game so you know this
is a team that that maybe was unlucky
early and to give joe judge the credit
he deserves
he held it together it didn't crater it
didn't crumble they kept doing what it
is that they needed to do and look
they're undefeated since the week 11 by
week and that was the week that he told
mark columbo get the hell out of here
and i thought that could blow up on him
and it didn't that ended up being
perhaps the best move he's made it's
galvanized the team and here they are
with their signature win
on the day that the browns got their
signature win over the titans the giants
got their signature win over the
seahawks chris yeah i mean it was
impressive it was it's a signature win i
mean signature win i think it's beyond
that for the new york giants i mean you
know me i'm a giants fan
there hasn't been much to root for here
the last few years this is a as big a
win i think for the giants football team
and i'm serious mike when do you think
this is the biggest win in the last two
or three years really for the
organization in a lot of ways and i
think you know between the winning
streak we're looking at right now and
some of the games you talked about hey
like teams like the rams they they don't
want to play the giants in the first
round
as much as that might look good on paper
and everything like that the giants have
some redeeming qualities that i think
are you know what what's really helping
them the first thing is o-line has come
together and i think you saw dave you
know dave i'm going to mess his name up
again google
i got it the googly elmo yep i should
know this i mean i only grew up around
nine million italian people in northern
jersey but either way heath adds an
attitude to the football team but the
biggest thing yesterday to me and we've
talked about this a lot mike is the size
of that giant's front on the defensive
side of the ball and the fact that they
can just rely on those four guys more
times than not and say we're not helping
you we're we got russell wilson and dk
metcalf here we're not putting any
safeties in the box we're not blitzing
we're keeping people back in coverage
and we think you big suckers up front
can handle it all and you know just to
say how big they are i mean when you
have a guy like leonard williams who's
your defensive end he's he's 295 300 300
pound player that just tells you the
size of their defensive front overall
and to me that was the thing that was
their biggest advantage yesterday and
stuck out about the football game
and this is a team that hasn't won a
postseason game since super bowl 46. man
they've been to the playoffs once since
then it was the boat trip loss to the
green bay packers 2016. ben mcadoo took
the team to that level and i was just
scrolling through their their victories
from 2016. i mean nothing really jumps
off as this level this magnitude going
into seattle beating one of the best
teams in the conference
in their own building a place where it's
very difficult to win even when the when
no fans are there with a backup
quarterback with colt mccoy
this was
the moment we saw that daniel jones was
doubtful with the hamstring injury
suffered last week against the bengals
we just did you scratch it off oh giant
there's no way the giants are going to
win this game they're not going to go
out there and win it right that this
this was the and
several teams this year the way it's
fallen the way the schedule has gone
they've gotten the new york teams back
to back the browns get them coming up
back to back the seahawks are in the
midst of back to back the 49ers got them
back to back and we just thought this is
two easy wins for the seahawks the talk
last week hey they got the easiest
schedule down the stretch and they're
just gonna
they're gonna get on a roll and maybe
they're gonna be the one seed well not
if they play like they did yesterday
especially against the backup
quarterback and daniel jones and now
they got to get themselves right for the
the jets coming can i even say that with
a straight face yeah not really that was
right for the jets
the jets reeling the jets turning one
loss into two or twelve or 12.
let's hear from russell wilson on what
went wrong yesterday for that team's
offense uh whatever he cooked caused a
case of food poisoning for everyone
involved here he is
i think the reality of this story was we
went we weren't able to capitalize on
opportunities you know um
you know i always talk about them game
altering plays you know we didn't have
those plays unfortunately today
um like we feel like we've had you know
for the most part all season you know
we've done a great job of those and um
those just didn't show up as much today
you know unfortunately and they stopped
us on some key situations you know
situational football they stopped us so
you know and then they score you know
right afterwards so i think that's where
it was
let me be fair here because a couple of
weeks ago i thought aaron rodgers wasn't
sufficiently upset after the packers
lost to the goals i feel like russell
wilson's trying to sell me a reverse
mortgage yeah a little bit right yeah i
don't know i mean i know what you mean
you're right it was like he was sitting
there ready he was ready to tell a story
of the game and why it went wrong
certainly i mean you're right it was a
little odd that way i i know he takes it
personal as i do aaron rodgers i know
that it does come off sometimes yes
these guys can compartmentalize it
because you're it's your life everything
you got to try to move on and just go
from there i'm i i promise you when he
sat on the couch when he got home with
his family he went there and went man i
can't believe we lost that game and i
bet you had bothered him all night but
it was a little bit of a weird look
there i'm with you
you just have to wonder how it does
affect their confidence going forward
and what you can do
to get things right after a game like
that where
you just feel like nothing that you
believe in nothing that you are your
identity didn't work and and what the
hell do you do going forward when you've
had such a great season
up until the past few weeks and he's
been plummeting
plummeting in the mvp
race plummeting he's behind patrick
mahomes and aaron rodgers going into
this week because he may fall even
farther behind a guy like a ben
roethlisberger maybe even baker mayfield
is going to start shooting up the ladder
after what he was able to do yesterday
against tennessee but you saw those
sacks 21 over the last that's the big
one
i and and and i i'm just it's it's
perplexing especially because that
narrative got locked in so early in the
season and we love our september
narratives because then we don't have to
use any additional brain power to go
back and change them but but it feels
like a very long time ago that the
seahawks seemed to be soaring to the one
seed and russell wilson seemed to be
headed to
a unanimous mvp award chris yeah no that
that's gone i mean i i mvp
yeah i don't i think that's out the door
maybe he gets a few votes it's gonna
take something special down the stretch
for him to like get back there and
they're gonna need to run the table
maybe you know maybe can lose one other
game but are going to have to do
something
statistically pretty special but i don't
see how you could watch it right now and
think that his play is on par with
rogers and and mahomes and you know
yesterday specifically mike you know
this patrick graham defensive
coordinator for the giants i know you've
heard me talk about him a few times we
talked about the defensive line you know
what they did their ability to rush and
collapse the pocket with four people
constantly just like we talk about with
any great quarterback i don't know what
they were doing on the back end i won't
really know until i watched film but it
was always coverage there was always
eyes on russell wilson and he seemed
uncomfortable as far as not that he was
getting pressured right as he dropped
back all game long but just never seemed
like he was throwing a ball on rhythm
like hey one two three four five hit
step throw that guy's open boom now here
we go it was always get to the top of
the drop let me hop because nobody's
open let me move and hop a little bit
more nobody there again and
obviously good game planning on the
giant side of the ball but yeah the
offense for the eagles has been a little
bit hit i mean the the seahawks has been
a little bit hit or miss lately
and uh
it is amazing when you think how the
weapons have developed there and maybe
it's a good thing that they get
josh gordon in a few weeks maybe they
need him dk metcalf and tyler locket not
able to get it done they were getting
covered yesterday and the fact that the
sacks averaged 4.8 seconds right the
five seconds that just shows you that
shows you that that they were
confusing russell wilson not letting him
think guys were open keeping guys from
getting open keeping him from getting
rid of the football and forcing him to
hold on to it and then doing the hard
part which is tracking him down and
corralling him you know seeing him
against kyle murray twice this year
really
took a little bit of that gleam off of
the the idea that he darts around like
the tasmanian devil he's not as as fast
and as elusive as kyler murray but still
he's one of the most elusive
quarterbacks in the nfl and it's amazing
to think that that uh he he got himself
sacked so many times when he did have
time for the play to develop and to bail
out on it and take off if that's what we
want to do we've seen him do that so
many times that's the other credit to
the giants not only did they cover the
receivers they sealed off the running
lanes for russell wilson they definitely
did and you know if anybody that watched
the game or you know you see see
highlights or whatever you'll see so
many times where
you know they don't real they never
over pursued right that's where we see
people get in trouble with russell
wilson the the all out pin your ears
pass rush they fly by him on the edge
and now there's these big gaps in front
of him and of course big defensive
tackles aren't going to stop him but the
giants didn't play it that way they
played like we've heard coach dungey and
rodney talk about so much what new
england does to scrambling quarterbacks
and of course this is the new england
coaching staff and that's what they
carried over there so that was really
impressive you know they took away
the two things
you know that we think are special about
the seahawks and that's russell wilson
and dk metcalf i know metcalf had five
for 80 but it was you know too few and
far between and a lot of it was late in
the football game so uh
i don't know mike you tell me i mean
we've gone from the seahawks to
wow they look unbelievable russell
wilson's gonna win the mvp looks like
they're gonna be win the number one seed
to now we're sitting here
i mean they're they're in danger of like
you could sit here and go i mean the
playoffs the playoffs are a real
conversation down after that loss
yesterday
with their schedule coming up and some
of the teams they got i mean
i don't know where this goes it's going
to be kind of interesting to watch here
down the stretch
well it definitely is and there are
going to be some good teams that don't
make it in the nfc because you've got
the vikings you've got the car
the cardinals are still in it and the
49ers are coming up hard and they finish
the season against the seahawks wouldn't
it be something if one year after it was
seahawks 49ers for the one seed
it becomes seahawks 49ers as a playoff
game as a playoff elimination game as a
early playoff game the winner gets in
the loser goes home that's entirely
possible in the nfc and you know one
nice thing about the giants because we
we we
you know colt mccoy only had 105 passing
yards so it's not like he came out and
lit it up he did what he needed to do
wayne goldman well yeah let's hit that
wayne go i mean saquon barkley gone
early in the year with the torn acl that
he suffered against the bears
and wayne goldman with 135 rushing yards
on 16 carries
and alfred morris a guy who could have
been should have been maybe would have
been offensive rookie of the year back
in 2012 the guy whose claim to fame was
he was still driving in 1991 mazda626
when he was drafted
he was gone he was done it was over yeah
alfred moore scores two touchdowns
yesterday i mean this seahawks defense
just when we thought it was coming back
you can't you can't lose to back up
quarterback back up running back and
running back who you know has like a
flash of oh yeah i remember alfred
morris every three or four years now
yeah i i mean it's disheartening for a
team like seattle who's putting you know
they they consider themselves super bowl
caliber but that's really you know other
than early in the game the seahawks blew
a few opportunities they were up three
nothing they were driving russell wilson
fumbled a snap they blocked a punt and
blew an opportunity to score a touchdown
and only got a safety that was a big
moment in the game it was only seahawks
around someone's got to bat that ball
back in the field to play so the
seahawks get a touchdown instead of
recovering it out of bounds and only
getting a safety they left points on the
field other than that mike what you're
talking about you're exactly right it
was the biggest thing that happened in
the game the third quarter the giants o
line just took over the football game
you know there was there was two running
plays that i saw when i was keeping my
eye on the game yesterday one where
everybody just goes straight forward and
it's double team double team double team
and hey just get a body on a body and
let wayne goldman kind of figure out
where a hole is and go through there
they were just pushing the seahawks back
no problem and then the other one for
the big run down the left sideline and
they gashed them with this run a few
times where they pulled guards and
centers out on the edge and the seahawks
had nobody out there a few times to to
make a tackle or take on blockers or do
anything so yeah definitely
disheartening but as a giants fan very
exciting i am very excited about the way
the giants play the way they look on the
field jojo's attitude and everything
he's brought to the giants i think he's
already
he's you know what do i want to say he's
he's made me feel real good as a giants
fan he's put his stamp on the franchise
as far as he has an identity and how
he's going to coach the team and the
team has an identity and i think that's
cool here in new york at least
well first of all it's the first time
you've mentioned being a giants fan all
season so welcome back on to the hey hey
giants let's go well there was no reason
did we talk about it all season i don't
even know
second of all i don't understand how
you're a giants fan why still because
you played in the nfl you played for the
buccaneers i never played for the giants
and i admire the fact
that you maintained that little kid
rooting for his dad sure dynamic even
after you went through the meat grinder
literally and figuratively that would
have made you jaded about the whole
concept of being the fan
of the team that you grew up rooting for
because i just feel like once a guy goes
through it as a player and comes out on
the other side yeah it's pretty much
done it is it's i i know what you mean
it is like that i think in a lot of
cases for players or anything like that
and there was a part of me mike for a
while that i was mad at the giants i
mean they cut my dad after he went to
the playoffs and was you know the mvp of
the team and went to the pro bowl i was
pissed for a few years i became a
cowboys fan where i was like screw the
giants i'm mad at them but i'm a new
yorker i have too many good memories my
family's all giants fans and i'm just
i'm all with them so yeah it's i like
the bucks of course because they drafted
me uh but the giants still have my heart
and uh i'm excited and especially with
joe judge there a guy i worked with in
new england it's just cool to see
well all i'll say is this if daniel
jones had any boys in the range of eight
to ten years old colt mccoy would have
to worry about getting shaving cream in
his shoes today
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports